position
well computer agrees computer agrees
good enough
Queenie one Queen F1 now we are
expecting some Queen FC check
yeah some way of getting the screen to
E1 will be winning
yeah Queen FC Queen is the queen E1
looks quite straightforward
yeah this has to be winning
you will even take the time to put the
king in some manner of Defending G6 and
then go Queenie one
and there we go Queen F3 on the board
Queen FC on the board
King A4
yeah I don't see anything wrong with
Queen E3
well then probably white will try some
Queen D1 or something yeah Queen G2
I have to take advantage of that fact
that you're not and there you go 23
hours yeah and maybe and it's also
logical but you mentioned that you might
just move the king yeah King G7
B5 pushed yeah the spawn is not exactly
as fast as blacks but I mean I excuse me
well where are the checks so Queen E1
creamy and check King H6 I think that's
it and don't see checks yeah I don't see
any checks Queenie once he's just
winning
no stalemate no nothing no
no I think anyone finishes it
and Queenie one on the board
between B7 King H6 we expect
and I think that might be it yeah that's
it that's it yeah among those designs
wow what a match one one afterwards
what a comeback here for nepo we were
really worried about his position
and through good defense through
resources and a little bit of help from
his opponent
he brought it back the full way
yeah incredibly